MEGAN ANSDELL: OK.
Hello, everybody.
I'm very excited to be
here to share with you all
about the NASA Frontier
Development Lab
and its partnership
with Google Cloud.
So my name is Megan Ansdell.
I'm a postdoctoral
fellow at UC Berkeley
in the astronomy department.
My background is in astrophysics
and planetary science.
And today, I'm going
to tell you about FDL.
I participated in FDL
last year in 2018.
So the NASA Frontier
Development Lab
is a public private
partnership between NASA
and partners in industry
that specialize in space
and artificial intelligence.
And the goal of NASA FDL is
to create innovative solutions
to problems that are of
interest not just to NASA,
but to humanity in general.
So FDL has focused on problems
like planetary defense,
so trying to find asteroids
that might be on a collision
course with Earth before they
hit us so that we don't end up
like the dinosaurs.
Also looking at problems
like space weather
so trying to track
flares on our sun
so that we can better understand
the impacts to satellites
in orbit that we depend a lot
on, like our GPS satellites.
And the way this
works is that FDL
puts on an eight-week research
accelerator down at the SETI
Institute in Silicon
Valley over the summer.
And the way it
works is that there
are these four-person teams.
The teams are made up of two
space science subject matter
experts and two machine
learning researchers.
And they work very intensely
together for these eight weeks
on a challenge that's
been given to them.
So this past year for FDL,
there were five challenge areas.
It was space resources, space
weather, astrobiology, earth
observation, and exoplanets.
And each one of
these challenge areas
was supported by one of
our private partners.
And these private
partners are really
leaders in commercial AI.
So Google Cloud, of
course, but also companies
like KX, IBM, NVIDIA, and Intel.
And we also had support
from some of the leaders
in private space, so companies
like Lockheed Martin and Space
Resources.
So this is the 2018
NASA FDL cohort.
We're all smiling
and looking fresh
faced because this is the
beginning of the summer.
We looked very much more
tired at the end of it,
but for good reasons.
So we were a very
interdisciplinary and diverse
group.
This is a very special
group of people.
About 50% of us were
based in the United States
as researchers.
The other 50% were
from around the world.
A lot of us were
PhD's, so some of us
had PhD's in astrophysics.
Others had PhD's in things
like computer vision, robotics.
It was a wide range.
There are also
people from industry
that came from companies
like Hyperloop and Apple,
Audi, just to name a few.
And it's really because
of our partnerships
with companies like Google
Cloud that we could all
come together for
the summer and work
on these really
exciting challenges
through this very unique
program of NASA FDL.
So we also had some pretty
amazing data sets to work with.
Sometimes NASA gave
us these data sets.
Other times, we had to
generate the data sets
using the wonderful compute
power tools through companies
like Google Cloud.
This particular data set was
used by the space weather team
this last year.
This is a real image of our sun
taken by NASA Solar Dynamics
Observatory, which is in
Earth orbit right now.
And it looks for
activity on the sun
so that we can better understand
the impact of that on Earth.
So to analyze
these data sets, we
had access to a very diverse AI
toolkit and just vast amounts
of compute power,
again, provided to us
by our private partners.
And I have to say, so I'm
a scientist in academia,
and this was truly amazing.
We do not have access to
resources like this normally.
And it was very eye opening
to see what kind of science
could be done in an incredibly
short amount of time
when you're given just the best
resources that are available.
So today, I'm going to
talk to you about two
of the challenges from last
year's NASA FDL program
that were made possible
through this partnership
with Google Cloud.
So that is the planet challenge
and the astrobiology challenge.
So I'll talk about the
exoplanet challenge first
because that was a team that I
was fortunate enough to be on.
So this is the exoplanet team.
So I was one of the
subject matter experts
as a planetary scientist.
Again, I'm at UC Berkeley.
Hugh Osborne was the
other planetary scientist.
He's in Marseilles.
And then the two
deep learning experts
were Yani Ioannou,
who just graduated
from the University at Cambridge
with a PhD, Michele Sasdelli,
who was a recovering
astrophysicist
and is now at the
University of Adelaide
with their computer
vision group.
We had some great mentors,
both on the science and machine
learning side, and of
course, our compute resources
were provided by Google Cloud.
OK, so the challenge
that we had was
to increase the efficacy and
yield of exoplanet transit
classification
with deep learning.
So I'm going to break
that down for you,
and I'll start with
the exoplanet side.
So first of all,
what is an exoplanet?
So everybody knows
our solar system.
There's the sun.
The sun is a star.
There are eight
planets in orbit.
No boos about Pluto not
being a planet anymore?
All right.
There are eight-- there you go.
So there are eight
planets in orbit.
And so an exoplanet
is just a planet
that's orbiting another star.
There are 100 billion
stars in our galaxy.
And we can now say
that on average,
every single one
of them contains
at least one exoplanet.
And that's pretty amazing
that I can stand up
here and say this today.
So the first exoplanet
was discovered in 1995.
So exoplanet science is
actually an incredibly new field
in astrophysics.
And we now know that we've
detected thousands of them,
and we can start studying
them as a population.
We can start doing
things like estimating
the frequency of Earth-like
planets around sun-like stars.
And one of the reasons
why we can do that
is because of the wonderful
success of a particular method
for detecting
exoplanets, and that's
called the transit method.
That's what's being
shown on the left here.
So the transit method works
by just taking advantage
of the fact that if you
see an exponent system
at a particular orientation,
when a planet goes in front
of its host star, you see a
drop in brightness of that host
star.
And that should be
a periodic thing.
Every time the
planet goes around,
you should see a
drop in brightness.
So we don't actually
resolve what's
being shown on the
far left there.
We don't actually see
the star and the planet.
What we do is what's
in the middle there,
we measure the
brightness of the star.
And we just wait for
that drop in brightness.
And we wait for a repeating
drop in brightness.
So one of the reasons why the
transit method is so successful
is because of a mission
called the Kepler spacecraft.
How many people here have
heard of the Kepler spacecraft?
That's fantastic.
So Kepler was in space
for about 10 years,
but actually, its
primary mission,
which gave us all the data we
worked with in this project,
was only going on
for about four years.
And so during this time,
Kepler stared at one position
in the sky for four
years, and looked
at about half a million stars,
and measured the brightness
of those stars every 30
minutes, and was just waiting
for these drops in brightness.
And through this
method, Kepler was
able to discover over
2,500 exoplanets.
So this is pretty amazing.
This completely revolutionized
the field of exoplanet science
and brought us to
where we are today.
But Kepler data isn't pretty.
So everything I showed you--
those wonderful plots--
it looks great.
That's not what we deal
with on a day-to-day basis.
So the top plot here is
what we call a light curve.
So this is a particular
star that Kepler looked at
and the brightness that
was measured every 30
minutes for about 750 days.
And you see all this stuff.
You see this ramping up.
You see these drops
in brightness.
So some of that is
spacecraft systematic.
Some of it's instrument noise.
Some of it's actual
stellar variability.
And only these
little bitty drops
that are highlighted
by the red triangles
are the exoplanet transit.
So this is one exoplanet.
You see three transits in
this particular time period.
And so we do a bunch of stuff
to flatten these light curves.
So on the bottom panel is you
see a flattened light curve.
So it's been cleaned of all
these systematic stellar
variability, and all you
see are the transits.
But this is actually
pretty nice data.
It gets a lot worse than this.
In particular, when you
have more than one planet.
So this is a now
famous planetary system
called the TRAPPIST system.
And you see when you have
multiple planets going around,
you start getting
overlapping transits.
It's very hard to sort
of tease all this out.
So it's hard to work with this
data and find these exoplanets.
Another reason why it's hard
to find these exoplanets
is because there's a variety
of false positive signals
that mimic exoplanet
transits, and we need
to find these and vet them out.
So one of the main
sources of false positives
are eclipsing binaries.
So here, you don't have
a planet orbiting a star.
You actually have two
stars orbiting each other.
One is usually smaller
than the other.
And so you can get
things that look a lot
like an exoplanet transit.
Particular nasty case are these
background eclipsing binaries.
So your target star is
actually a single star,
but there's an eclipsing
binary in the background
that you can't resolve.
And that can actually look a
lot like an exoplanet transit.
And then there are
chance alignments
of stellar variability,
instrument noise.
The example that I
showed before, there
were three transits.
And you can imagine
that in some cases,
you get chance alignment
of three things that
look like they're on
a periodic cadence.
And so you get these
false positives that way.
And that becomes a problem when
you dig into the lowest signal
to noise transits,
which unfortunately,
usually correspond to the most
interesting cases of things
like Earth-like planets
inhabitable zones
around sun-like stars, which
was the whole point of Kepler.
So you have to vet for
all these false positives.
So the way we do
this, the Kepler team
developed this very
sophisticated pipeline,
and I'll go through
this very quickly,
but this is sort of
how we traditionally
find exoplanet transits.
So we start off with what are
called target pixel files.
These are little postage
stamp images of stars.
This is what's actually
downloaded from the spacecraft.
Then we use what we call
aperture photometry,
so you put down an aperture.
You sum all the light
within that aperture,
and that's how
bright the star is.
You do that as a
function of time,
and you get those light curves
that I showed you before that
have all the systematics in it.
You flatten those.
Then you do an exoplanet
transit search,
so you start looking
for these transits,
and you record everything
above a certain signal
to noise threshold.
You pass that through a
data validation stage.
So this is just-- you start
fitting transit models.
You start calculating
statistics that can help
you identify false positives.
And this is an
iterative process.
So you find one transit, you
block out the light curve,
you send it back into the
transit planet search.
Because as we know
from our solar system,
stars can host many planets.
Then when you're done, you feed
all of this to a set of humans.
Humans sit down.
These are people's jobs,
which is kind of cool.
Their job is to just
find exoplanets.
So they sit around, and they
look at hundreds of thousands
of these transit events.
And they figure out which
ones are real exoplanets
and which are not.
And this is a very
time-consuming process.
You're sifting
through a lot of data.
It took years in
the case of Kepler.
But at the end of the day, we
get these wonderful exoplanet
catalogs, and we can start
answering questions like,
how common is our
Earth in the galaxy?
But this last part, this
last very time-consuming part
is where deep learning can
help and where it already
is helping.
And today, I'm going to tell
you about how we did that.
So now I'll move on to the deep
learning side of what we did
and in particular, how Google
Cloud helped us do this.
So I'm going to give you
a 30 second introduction
to deep learning for people who
aren't too familiar about it.
So deep learning is a
subset of machine learning.
It's called deep
learning because it
uses a series of
computational layers
to basically take
inputs, translate them
into more useful outputs
by learning increasingly
complex features in the data.
Neural networks are a
type of deep learning.
They're called neural networks
because their architecture
sort of is loosely analogous
to the neurons in our brain.
And then convolutional
neural nets
are a type of
neural network that
takes advantage of spatial
features in the data.
And they're particularly good at
classification problems, which
is essentially what we're doing.
We're saying is this a planet,
or is this not a planet.
So the reason why we
want to use deep learning
for exoplanet transit science,
there's a bunch of them.
So one, it's quick.
You train a model.
And then you can classify
hundreds of thousands
of candidate planet transits
within seconds, instead of
years.
It's systematic, so
this human vetting
that I talked to you
about, it's full of biases
that you can't tease out.
So I didn't have
coffee this morning.
I saw an eclipsing
binary the last time
I tried to vet a candidate.
I've seen planets the last 10
times I've looked at planets.
All of this stuff biases
your decision making process,
and it's really hard to
tease out those biases
and correct for them.
And so having a systematic
way of doing this
is really important, and it's
important for calculating
all these exoplanet statistics
that we're interested in.
As we'll see from
this presentation,
there's also easy to
upgrade these models.
So you want to
improve your model.
It's easy to retrain
and apply to new data.
And it's quantifiable,
so you're not just
saying this is an exoplanet.
This is not an exoplanet.
You're saying this is
an exoplanet with 0.8
plus or minus 0.1 probability.
And again, you can fold that
into these exoplanet statistics
and make them a lot more robust.
So the first people to
actually apply deep learning
to exoplanet transit
classification
was Shallue and Vanderburg 2018.
So Chris Shallue
works at Google Brain.
Andrew Vandenburg is a postdoc
in astrophysics, like myself.
And they made a model
called Astronet.
It's available on
GitHub if you want
to download it and play with the
model in the model architecture
shown on the right.
But basically, it's a deep
convolutional neural network.
It was written in TensorFlow.
And the inputs are these
global and local views
of the phase-folded
candidate transit.
So what I mean by
phase-folded is
that I showed you these light
curves before that spanned four
years.
But there's a signal in
there that's periodic.
So you can fold the light
curve on that period,
and you get these nice
exoplanet transits that
are shown on the bottom here.
So they input these
global and local views.
The global views are
important because it
shows you the whole transit.
So in the case of these
eclipsing binaries that I told
you about, when they're two
stars eclipsing each other,
you actually get a primary
and a secondary clip.
So you get an eclipse
when the smaller
star goes in front
of the bigger star
and also when it goes behind.
And that's because
you're dealing
with two very bright objects.
You don't see that with a planet
because a planet is small.
And it doesn't have its
own brightness to it.
So that's important
for identifying things
like eclipsing binaries.
The local view zooms in
on the transit and maps
out its shape in more detail.
And this is important because
true planet transits actually
have a pretty unique shape,
the kind of a box-like shape.
That's actually one of the
ways that we can detect them.
And that's just because
the planet is so small,
compared to the whole star.
So both of these are important.
They're fed in as separate
disjoint one-dimensional
convolutional columns
into the model.
The outputs of the
convolution columns
are flattened and
concatenated, then fed
through a series of
fully connected layers,
and then a sigmoid layer.
And the output is this
number between 0 and 1,
which loosely represents
the likeliness
of that particular
transit being associated
with a true exoplanet.
So Astronet did
something really cool--
discover two new super Earths
in two different systems.
Super Earths are really cool
because we don't have them
in our solar system.
So if you imagine our solar
system was shown on the bottom
here, we have the rocky
planets in our solar system.
And then we have
the big gassy ice
giants on the outer solar
system and nothing in between.
So supers are cool
because we don't have them
in our own solar system.
They're also really cool
because it turns out
what we know from Kepler
now is that they're by far,
the most common type of
planet in the galaxy.
So they're important and we
need to learn about them.
So the Kepler 90 system
was also a sun-like star,
so it was a super Earth
around a sun-like star.
And it brought that system.
It brought it up to eight
planets in the system.
So it's actually the system in
our galaxy with the most known
exoplanets, and it
brings it up a tie
with our own solar system.
So what we did over
the summer through FDL
was to upgrade Astronet
with what we call added
scientific domain knowledge.
So it's just information
that us scientists
had that could improve
the model performance.
And it ended up improving
it for, in particular,
the low signal to noise transits
that correspond to Earth
sized planets.
And we called our
model Exonet, and it's
also available on GitLab if you
want to check the model out.
The updated architecture's
on the right.
But what I wanted
to do, before I
get into the science
side of it, was just
highlight the role
of Google Cloud.
So Google Cloud was really
sort of the glue that held
the whole project together.
So through it, we could
make our code in Python
through a collaborative
environment of the Jupyter
notebooks.
We called on PyTorch
and scikit-learn
to build, and test,
and train our models.
And the whole thing was
incredibly seamless.
And I walked into
the FDL program
with no machine learning
experience, very little
collaborative coding
experience, and Google Cloud
made the whole thing incredibly
easy to learn and to pick up.
Each of our team members
had custom instances.
We had our own virtual machines.
So we could sort of customize
these machines to whatever
we happened to be doing at that
moment, whether it was building
the model, or training
it, or testing it.
We had access to
amazing GPU resources.
And we used a persistent
solid state drive
for reading our data
quickly for training.
And so again, I just want
to highlight as an academic,
this was absolutely amazing.
Let me give you some insight
into how it works in academia.
So we typically
apply for a grant
to NASA or the National
Science Foundation.
And sometimes those grants
let us buy hardware.
And so we say we want
to buy this hardware.
It's usually not v100's,
because then we would not
get the grant approved.
But you get some
money for hardware
if you're lucky enough,
and then you go off
and you buy that hardware.
And then you use that hardware
for on the order of five to 10
years, sometimes longer.
And then you get another
grant, and the whole process
starts over again.
So it's very slow, and so our
resources are not just limited,
but they're out of date.
So to have the resources that
are provided by Google Cloud
was pretty amazing.
OK, so what did we add to our
model to increase the model
performance?
So one of the things
we added first
was a centroid time-series.
So I showed the
light curves before,
which is just how bright the
star is as a function of time.
The other thing you
get from this data--
so I mentioned before
what we actually
get from the spacecraft are
these postage stamp images.
So you can lay down an aperture
and measure the brightness
within that aperture.
But you can also measure the
pixel position of the center
of light within that aperture.
And that's called the centroid.
And you get that as
a function of time.
So in this case,
let's say you have
a background eclipsing binary.
When that eclipse happens
on that background source,
the centroid will
actually shift.
It'll shift away
from that binary.
And you can use that information
to identify false positives.
So this is what I mean.
So again, these
global and local views
of the phase-folded transit.
On the top is a real exoplanet.
So you see the transit,
but you don't see a shift
in the centroid,
which is shown in red.
On the bottom is a
background eclipsing binary,
and you can see in
the transit, you
get the shift in the centroid.
So you can take advantage
of that information.
And so the way we did that was
to create secondary channels
in the convolutional
columns and to feed
in the centroid time-series
along with a light curve.
The other thing we did was
add stellar properties.
So one thing I didn't mention is
that with this transit method,
the planet properties
you get out
actually heavily depend on the
properties of the host star.
So one of the things we did was
tell the model the properties
of that particular host star.
And there's a variety of
reasons why this might help,
but I'm showing
one of them here.
So here, you have a
giant star being orbited
by a main sequence star.
And I'll explain
what that means.
So if you have a binary system.
And by the way, half
the stars in our galaxy
are binary system.
So our sun is
single, but actually,
50% of the stars in
the galaxy are binary.
So this is an important effect.
When you have a
binary system, they
don't evolve at the same rate.
They don't age at the same rate.
Usually, one ages
quicker than the other.
And when happens,
the star blows up.
It becomes a giant star.
We call it a giant star
because we have no imagination.
But it gets really puffy.
Our sun is going to do
that, and when it does that,
it will actually
engulf the Earth.
So that's how big these
things are getting.
But you can see the size
difference is actually really
similar to a star and a planet.
So you can get exoplanet
transits or things
that look like
exoplanet transits,
when really, it's just an old
star with a middle aged star
orbiting it.
So we fed in the
stellar parameters.
We concatenated
them to the outputs
of the convolutional columns
before the fully connected
layers, and that's how we took
advantage of that information.
So we were able to
increase the model
performance over the baseline
Astronet by a few percent.
Astronet was already
performing really well,
so that increase of
just a few percent
actually corresponded to about
50% decreases in model error.
And there's a
precision recall curve
shown on the right that shows
you that the centroids actually
provided the best boost
to the model performance,
but the stellar
properties also helped.
What was interesting, though,
is not just the overall model
performance, but it
turns out that we
were getting much better
recall, almost 20%
higher gains in
recall for exoplanets
that corresponded to--
that had the lowest transit
signal to noise ratio.
And these correspond
to Earth sized planets.
So what it's telling us
is that our model Exonet
might be able to find Earth
sized planets still lurking
in the Kepler data.
And that's what we're
working on right now.
OK, so at the end
of the day, we were
able to show that scientific
domain knowledge improves
exoplanet transit classification
with deep learning.
And all the scientists
let out a big sigh
that their jobs are not being
taken by the machines just yet.
Probably soon, though.
OK, so that was the
exoplanet challenge,
and now I'll spend
some time talking
about the astrobiology
challenge.
My colleague Molly O'Beirne
was supposed to be here.
But unfortunately,
she couldn't make it.
So I'm going to
do the best I can
to share with you their work.
So this is the astrobiology
team from last year.
So Molly O'Beirne
and Michael Himes
were the planetary scientists.
And Frank Soboczenski
and Simone Zorzan
were the computer scientists.
They also had wonderful mentors
on the science and machine
learning side, and of
course, Google Cloud
was the industry partner.
OK.
Are we alone?
That's a question that's
been asked for hundreds,
if not thousands, of years.
And what's really exciting is
that we're actually at a time
when we might be able
to answer this question.
In the near future, we might
be able to detect signatures
of life on another planet.
So the first step is
finding those other planets,
and as I just showed you, we're
getting pretty good at that.
But the next step after
that is to figure out
which one of those planets
is most suitable for life,
and therefore, where we
should look for life.
Where is the most likely
place that we can detect life?
And that's the hard part.
That's still pretty hard.
So the challenge for
the astrobiology team
was to use machine learning
to try and identify
possible extraterrestrial
life on other worlds.
Sounds pretty easy, right?
But they did have
a starting point.
So what scientists
think they want to do
is to look at the
atmospheres of exoplanets
and in particular, to look
for molecules or groups
of molecules in those
atmospheres that
are indicative of
biological activity
on the surface of those planets.
And so those are collectively
called biosignatures.
And we can actually do this.
We can detect molecules in
the atmospheres of exoplanets,
but only for these hot Jupiters,
so very massive planets
very close to their star.
And the way we do this
is we get a spectrum.
So we use telescopes
in space to get
a spectrum of the atmosphere.
And that spectrum
has fingerprints
of these molecules.
And we use something called
atmospheric retrieval
to infer the actual
composition of that atmosphere
from that spectrum.
The problem is that
atmospheric retrieval--
the traditional way of doing it
is incredibly time-consuming.
So it takes days, if not
weeks, on supercomputers
to actually back out atmospheric
composition from a spectrum.
So this is where machine
learning, a different approach
can speed this up.
So the astrobiology team
created a code called INARA.
It stands for the Intelligent
Exoplanet Atmospheric
Retrieval.
So INARA is really cool.
It's an all-in-one
flexible, open source tool.
So it starts by generating
planetary spectra
using NASA's Planetary
Spectrum Generator, or PSG.
So the reason why
the astrobiology
had to generate its data
is what I just mentioned.
We can only measure
exoplanet atmospheres
for these hot Jupiters.
For Earth like planets,
it's much more difficult.
We're not quite
there yet, but there
are plans for spacecraft in the
future to be able to do this.
And so this is very
important precursor work.
And so what NASA's Planetary
Spectrum Generator does
is it'll produce a
synthetic spectrum based
on certain spacecraft
configurations and a given
planetary atmosphere.
So they created these spectra.
They can be saved locally
or to a Google Cloud bucket.
And then there's
other INARA instances
that can pull that data out,
and then on the fly, train,
and validate, and test
the machine learning
model and to predict these
planetary atmospheres.
And this is available as a
Python package or a Docker
container.
And the astrobiology
team created 3 million
of these simulated
rocky exoplanet spectra.
And these are
different combinations
of about 28 planetary
and stellar properties.
And it output 12
atmospheric models,
including these biosignatures.
So this is by far
the largest library
of exoplanet spectra
there is available,
and it's all publicly available.
So this is more of a visual
way of what I just said.
So this is the INARA Google
Cloud Platform landscape.
So there was the
data generation size,
and again, 3 million
unique spectra.
And they used 2,000 Google Cloud
virtual machines to do this.
So the way it was
laid out is that there
were these virtual machine
nodes that had the NASA PSG
tool on them, and then
16 INARA Docker instances
were connected to
each of those nodes,
querying the PSG
to make spectra.
And then those instances
were saving the spectra
to a Google Cloud bucket.
And then there were
separate INARA machine
learning training instances that
were connected to that Google
Cloud bucket actively reading
those out and training
the models on the fly.
And the astrobiology
team did a grid search
of 70 model architectures,
primarily written in PyTorch,
but they also explored
different frameworks using
[? Karas and ?] TensorFlow.
And what's also
cool about this is
that if you had a project
that was sort similar to this,
you can take this framework and
just input your own spectrum
generator, or what
generator of whatever,
and then input your own
machine learning model.
And so this whole
framework is set up,
and you can actually
just play and play
whatever you need for
your science needs.
So this is the model
architecture they decided on.
In the end, it's actually quite
similar to the exoplanet one.
It's a series of one-dimensional
convolutional layers
with MaxPooling, which were
then fed through some fully
connected layers at the end.
So this is a result from just a
random planet from their sample
only for five molecules.
So it's a bit hard
to see, but there
are some red stars
that are the true value
of that planetary atmosphere.
And then the sort
of colorful blobs
are the predictions
from the model.
And you're getting
a distribution
because this was actually
a Bayesian deep learning
model that took advantage
of concrete dropout
to create these
posterior distributions.
So you can see it does pretty
well for these molecules.
But it actually
predicts 12 molecules.
This is much more than other
planetary retrieval methods.
And of course,
the big benefit is
that this is created in
seconds, whereas previously,
atmospheric retrieval requires
days to do the same thing.
All right, so in the end,
the astrobiology team
generated 3 million
rocky exoplanet spectra
and developed its first machine
learning atmospheric retrieval
model for rocky terrestrial
exoplanets, like the earth.
So this is pretty amazing.
And it's all publicly
available, if you
wanted to play around with it.
OK, so that's all
I had for you now.
I've had a great time
sharing with you.
I hope you've had a great
time learning about some
of the cool science that can be
done through the Google Cloud
Platform.
And I just want to
finish by saying,
this was an amazing
experience for me
to go through this program.
Again, I had zero
machine learning
experience going into this.
And the tools that are available
through the Google Cloud
Platform made it not just easy
to learn, but also enjoyable
and fun to learn.
So I'm very excited to see
all the future science that
can come out of collaborations
with the Google Cloud Platform.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]